hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
rain okay I've totally forgotten
everything that I was doing yeah that's
it
okay so we're we just got some word
about some dude who went crazy and
locked himself into the thingy over
there and killed everyone inside so we
got to find a way to get into there um
there's a door that leads outside
there's a chain there's a padlock it's
also the stuff that doesn't really
interest me at all but I've got a flow
cycle rod so well why don't I go over
your guy okay so that's in there that's
a bunch of knobs and levers lever three
configuration must always be down down
down down configuration for levers 1 & 2
must align with their respective letters
sound lever set sound found in the
storage rooms however these levers can
only be shifted when all three flow rods
are installed correctly okay so the or
the or these must all be down down down
but I need more flow rods I'm assuming
that these are the storage room maybes
possibly storage B sometimes my grasp
upon this reality weakens and I find
myself slipping into another world
okay that's nice how about you not knew
that wall we're all piss kliklak light
ah it's almost cheerful mmm look at that
light once again I usually do not use
nearly enough tinderboxes when I am
adventuring into the depths so I'm
actually gonna you every single time I
see
nope nope nope nope nope no no no no no
no no nope nope nope nope nope nope
let's go to Sorge eh
I think storage a is much better than
storage B during my episodes this
mansion I find myself in this other life
saddens me it feels familiar as if I've
been here before but it's cold and
lonesome I don't know I don't want to
return I'm afraid to be dropped in the
world frightening world forever okay
there we go let's go and storage a which
sounds much better than whatever was in
that one step dorje yeah much much
better now let there's a moose man in
this one there was a grunting the other
one or a groan grunting a brooder the
official noise oh this one's already
pre-lit I should have gone in this one
first a while ago I cannot run though I
can't use my lantern either uh-oh I'm
going slow
I'm turning sideways I'm falling down
nope yep I'm probably down
all right then
fightin on reality was gonna start
unraveling out a gun down this way first
a while ago and I'm gonna oh this oh not
fair bro
maybe yeah maybe storage B was a better
option none of these seem like good
choices where's the water monster is he
nearby thought I heard something in
there the story of my life of amnesia I
thought I heard some let us see I think
I'm supposed to find some sort of set of
levers so that I can match him up
corresponding flee
that's not a good sound that's a bad
sound alright man jeez how much storage
do they need this isn't swords this is
complete basement there's nothing being
stored here besides sadness and despair
I guess here's storage I don't see any
rods I don't see any levers oh well oh
okay sure chunk let me guess it's gonna
lock behind me nope not yet
but there was a strange sound just like
all my other adventures into this
wonderful place that I live so much are
now they're tender buckles but here we
go what if we got here a Trinity rod
okay so this is number two it's down up
up up up down up up up up down up up up
number two is down up up up down up up
up down up up up down up up up big
yes down up up up uh-huh
is there a body part in here that I can
use ah ha ha ha and I what's it Hey look
a key is that a secret key aa secret key
Sooey
I'll have to be on a lookout for a
secret key in the next door there you go
dafuq you message it didn't eat it it
did it didn't need it I want to eat
slave on the stove all day for these
Jews eat orzo pits they won't eat y'all
eat
oh it's Ivan summoned yet yes another
waste of a perfectly good tour zone how
about you give me that you over there
and you [ __ ] off bets eat the Jews eat
orzo err filing
keep eating keep eating oh come on ah
go down go down got a plaster cast balls
Cass balls
is there another one what's the deal on
okay so there was not another one that
was this all in my mind
it sounded like it was right behind me
trying to buy me in the butt but
apparently not are there two doors
oh yeah cuz I already wanted to excuse
me I need to go away from here
you suck okay down up up up down up up
up down up up up down up up up down up
up up and I found a sacred secret key
I'm II don't know what that means and
don't know where to use it but I'm gonna
try to find it I mean I'm guessing it's
these pieces of what were these calls
Oscars relics who is a character on
Sesame Street I'm guessing they're gonna
combine into something else
I don't really know oh okay down up up
up four - it's a hot it's just in the
opposite so that's it wait maybe these
are all just in the opposite
configurations that's why they're easy
to remember
alright storage B when I chose the first
time I don't even know why I'm doing
this what is the point of this is this a
machinery to get the the the the the
chapel door open and why why do I want
to go in there just cuz Ulric wants to
go in there doesn't mean that it's a
good idea whatever
hello we're at that monster I heard so
much about see let me be careful doll
which one of these I like that was my
last one I believe secret key secret key
secret key secret key secret key nope
what are you gasping wool I heard that I
heard that I heard that did you all hear
that I heard that I didn't just okay ah
come on
not another dream sequence oh boy I'm
gonna make through this door before I
fall down drunk right by my bottles oh
yes tasty wine so much wine
alright looks about the same I'm
guessing these are flashbacks to when
this place wasn't so decrepit maybe or
well there's still a window there that
wasn't there for my okay now is this
place gonna fill with water
yeah there's no window here piss clunk
you didn't hear anything
you hear anything buddy what's that
buddy
what's that I need to find place to hide
nah need find place to run
hey come ooh hi ha ha I'm not in that
door ha ha ha you're such a silly Billy
I'm not in there OOP oh good job not
finding me
where'd you fail it's going to crash
very carefully Oh where'd he go
ha ha he's just one of those friendly
monsters like Casper oh I think much
times lost I feel that it's been months
since I set out Santillan shop you know
I still cannot find my way boy you're
dumb hm I've seen so much of this
accursed place I've been to escape
sewers storage rooms mechanical goals
and contractions my efforts with the
machinery of this cause would make me
feel like it's an organism that
sustained when my feeble attempts to
free myself his clutches yeah not really
I'm very much a part of this place no
you're not stop being crazy and I just
refilled my lantern what the heck
ok so yeah it is the opposite something
has gone into my eye again just like
before ah why does this keep happening
and how how does this keep happening
you know in no other time did something
usually fall into my eyeball but for so
hey buddy are you doing over there
secret key secret secret key secret key
secret key secret secret key secret ah
I got a box in front of my head you
can't see me can't see me
haha and done you can't uh Boosh Oh what
kind of boots miss me
ah no secret key there was I'm not going
to find it I'm just leading him in a
circle for the moment Oh
epic barrel jump at the Box jump how go
that should put some distance between me
and him what a nail here uh by misny
poop winner on the best he sucks there
probably wasn't a secret key in here cuz
there already was one oh it's hardly
fair top-heavy jump weight barrel jump
who's in here did I go in there about
how about here ah secret key takeaway
key secret key hi buddy ha ha ha we
light some candles for you ah
woo you look ugly
hey come back here don't run away from
me hi oh sweet whoops ah no well that's
convenient cuz it's probably gonna pour
me to the entrance oh no I'm back here
well I just wasted a bunch of time for
no gain at all so let's just carry on
our way and get out of here make like a
tree and get out of here
damnit I wasted a lot of time just
wandering around in circles I wanted to
do more than that stupid a hold those
you got those guys usually can't get me
in one shot I thought I was able to
sustain bit more maybe cuz I heard
myself in the other room probably ah
not you again alright sweet epic jumps
going around here oh what's that
Oh with that ha ha I'm not over there
it's such an a-hole get out of here I'm
the best you suck
game over I took longer than I thought
Oh hopelessness and despair it's
insanity I don't want to return it I'm
afraid of becoming trapped in that
frightening world forever yeah yeah blah
blah blah okay let me do this real quick
before I end this episode here and then
then we'll carry on my way what okay
chunk chunk ah come on
chunk wait a minute yeah that's right
these are all down oh no I really didn't
pay attention to what that was I just
assumed it was gonna be opposite so I
hope that is correct this configuration
is accepted this goes this way oh yeah I
know that one yeah that was that was
right because of number two is in gate B
your gate eh
that's right yeah I got the machinery
working which is good for something I
don't know what I still need to get that
padlock off that door for my salvation
and whatever but anyway so I got that
all taken care of so thank you all so
much watching click the annotation or
deduce it I've done and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye
Oh
buzz
Oh
Oh